(audience cheers)
♪ The door's unlocked ♪
♪ And you don't even have to knock ♪
♪ Or you can use the fireplace ♪
♪ I'll be waiting either way, hey ♪
♪ You come and go ♪
♪ And no one is supposed to know ♪
♪ But ever since you caught my stare ♪
♪ You know I know that you are real ♪
♪ Well, Santa I've been thinking ♪
♪ And I'm just needin' one thing ♪
♪ You to bring me something shiny ♪
♪ Like a diamond ring ♪
♪ Just a little something from Tiffany's ♪
♪ Oh, Santa, make my Christmas Eve ♪
♪ Four carats, please ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Mm something sparkly ♪
♪ Yellow canary ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Mm I'm waiting patiently ♪
♪ Santa, don't forget me ♪
♪ Ooh, don't forget me ♪
♪ Like a diamond ring ♪
♪ Just a little something from Tiffany's ♪
♪ Or a big ruby ♪
♪ You know red has always
looked good on me ♪
♪ I won't tell anyone ♪
♪ I've been good all year long ♪
♪ Oh Santa, make my Christmas Eve ♪
♪ Four carats, please ♪
(audience cheers)